este es el primer vídeo de una serie de
vídeos de khan academy en los que te voy
a mostrar cómo construir un robot este
robot tendrá ojos los ojos los haremos
con luz led y bueno primero vamos a
organizar todas las partes del robot
veremos cada uno de los componentes
entonces en este estuche tenemos dos
taparroscas dos interruptores dos
interruptores de un polo y doble tiro
dos motores de 1.5 volts y 4 clips
grandes también dos baterías dobles un
estuche para batería doble a silicon dos
luces led también dos resistor es que
sean compatibles con tus luces leds que
sean de menos de 60 oms y por último 5
cables de distintos colores
ahora hablemos de las herramientas que
necesitas para el proyecto necesitas una
pistola para silicón
unas pinzas de punta plana para doblar
los cables también algo para pelar los
cables ya sea un pelador de cables o
tijeras lo que sea que te funcione y
bueno iniciemos con esto